[Music]
rear window like many Hitchcock movies
captures the magnetism of voyeurism
you know Hitchcock he knew his audience
very well he knew they were coming to
his movies as voyeurs and there is a
sick twisted guilty little pleasure that
we as human beings have and watching
something we're not supposed to be
watching that movie captures that
feeling and packages it in a way that
puts us on the just side of the lead
character played by Jimmy Stewart where
we're we're deciphering a crime so it
really just tapped into the voyeur in
all of us Twilight Zone is a huge
undertaking a huge project and a
daunting one and I have just so much
respect for Serling I have so much
respect for the original series the
reason we decided to take it on was
because we felt like the world needed it
honestly what Serling did with that
original series was he pointed things
out through allegory through story he
pointed things out about our society he
sparked discussion he allowed us to
realize things about ourselves through
the entertainment genre and he did it on
television we are at a time right now
where here maybe once a day it feels
like we are in the twilight zone
and so it felt like it was time another
one of the greatest of all time psycho
just a crazy movie I love to like think
about what it must have been like in the
moment when some of these movies came
out because it's hard
in retrospect to really understand you
know we've seen all the films that have
been inspired by these movies we've seen
all of the serial killer movies that
have happened since psycho when that
movie came out it completely changed the
way people viewed cinema and it was an
enormous success at but at the same time
I think went into a darker place in the
human psyche than had
ever been attempted before also you know
Hitchcock a master of many things but
you know psycho was a pinnacle film in
in the artistry of subverting and
audiences expectations and what he did
with the Janet Lee character Marion
crane was he introduced you to a
protagonist and then just killed her 40
minutes into the movie no one saw that
coming and it just I don't even know if
anyone pulled that off yet there's a
since he just he pulled the rug out of
the entire idea of what it means to tell
a story Night of the Living Dead total
GameChanger
right we've got a black protagonist and
we've got a movie that is in itself an
allegory for for race and racial
discussion and and it's as mad early I
think you know I think get out came out
probably like 50 years after night at a
living dead my favorite thing about this
movie is that it's it's about something
important it's about something poignant
without being about it
all of a sudden a bunch of dead bodies
start rising from their graves and
attack the country they attack a house
and what you have is a black man and a
white woman end up in a house and you
see this little microcosm for this
racial dynamic where she's in shock but
you don't quite know where the shock of
being attacked by zombies or the shock
of being in this house with this black
dude who just is all business drops off
and picks up and then of course one of
the most crushing endings of all time
that really just sort of left an impact
and you know that movie alone Romero
just became an absolute horror icon that
movie really turned the idea of a zombie
into
like a household monster named halloween
is probably the greatest slasher film of
all time John Carpenter's masterpiece
and then you know I really get into you
know what I call the supernatural killer
franchise movies so you know I'm I'm an
eighties kids Nightmare on Elm streets
child's plays Candyman these movies that
are about a a killer that has special
powers there's something about that
dynamic of bringing in that sort of dark
magical element that is is sort of a
release it brings it to this realm with
imagination and it's not as depressing
as like it's just a traditional like
slasher where a dude is just killing
people and killing people we began to
see the world through the eyes of the
killers this is a really pretty grim
idea but obviously served some sort of
social purpose when we got to the 80s
and the supernatural killer isn't like
Freddy's out there killing you know
people and and you know doing like a bit
like dinner's served
you know when doing the the bit he
became like a surrogate for the audience
in this weird way and I feel like he
tapped in to some suppressed aggression
something that needed to get out and it
became this this different kind of
interactive experience where you start
cheering and rooting for the killer and
the the the the teenagers you know
become less and less likeable in their
portrayal so it's a really dark twisted
time really disturbed me as a kid but
you know anything that resonates
anything that works in the horror genre
I think it's doing it because of some
deep-seated societal reasons
then you know Candyman came along which
is a masterpiece and and one of the
things that it unlocked is what if the
supernatural killer was a black man that
was a for me in many ways
totally not okay and in many ways it was
this weird arrival to something that I
was I was longing for there's something
about horror movies especially when you
talk about in terms of the black
audience who really really shows up for
horror and I think really appreciates
horror and you know we will will yell at
the screen we will be interactive but
the the films never really served us our
identity and people with black skin
doesn't didn't fare very well and it's
it's just a kind of a confusing and
unfortunate thing for me growing up sort
of being in love with horror movies but
also not feeling very well represented
so that was a complete game-changer one
of the reasons I'm embarking on adding
to the the mythology of Candyman Blair
Witch Project was a game changer you
know that was just a study in how scary
you can make a movie with where it's
basically nothing happens and and a
masterpiece of anticipation and tension
I love the part of a horror movie where
we're living with the terror of what's
to come that's when the audience has the
ability to create their own nightmares
in their head and I'll go through all
those scenarios $0.06 I mean that movie
scared the [ __ ] out of me I have so much
respect for M night for just bringing
such an elevated contribution to the
horror genre one of the ways it's it's
particularly special is you know he's he
acting you know it's it's it is a horror
but it's also a drama the
performances in that movie are just
incredible
like Tony Colette's seen at the end of
that movie was just make you cry when
she's in the car with hailey Joe Osmond
and he sees the grandma outside of the
door like that makes me cry every time
and then you know of course of course
there's that amazing twist that
everybody knows now spoiler alert
there's a twist at the end of the sixth
sense I think what people are gonna find
in us is that I you know much like and
get out I I'm inspired by many many
different subgenres of horror and you
know I really tried to make something
that incorporates what I loved about
those and sort of steps into its own new
sub-genre
[Music]